we're going to start with the luncheon
address so I am delighted to introduce
Matt crows at his plane did land matt is
a senior policy advisor and analyst in
the Office of nuclear energy at the US
Department of Energy and he also serves
as vice chair of the nuclear development
committee and the co-chair of the
working party on nuclear economics at
the organization of Economic Cooperation
and Development nuclear energy agency so
Matt delighted to have you here and
ignore the munching in the background
please thank you I really appreciate the
opportunity to be here and given the
travails to get here I think I've lived
up to that I was very excited to have
the opportunity to to come to Yale and
speak on nuclear energy and climate
change its Gail has been held out as a
bastion a beacon of academic excellence
and intellectual enlightenment and
perhaps for that reason when i first had
the thought that would be coming to
speak I didn't think first about nuclear
technology or policy the things that I
do all day and my time thinking about
actually was immediately hearkened back
to my time in graduate school as a
political scientist and the mid 90s and
particularly I thought myself thinking
about one of Yale's great political
scientists Robert Dahl who so much of
the second half of 20th century thinking
a lot about how power democracy and
influence work together in a practical
sense and this idea of dal coming to
mind I decide I want to use this as a
bit of a lens to talk about how we
govern nuclear energy not just in the
form of the government itself but in the
broader set of institutions that oversee
it and as I begin to introduce doll I
have to offer a bit of an apology in the
outset you see
I'm important my life were I've been
reading more Rowell doll to my kids than
I have Robert Dahl on the side and last
ten years and also there's a chance that
I kind of got some of the original
message is garbled because you when I
left to lay in 1994 I offered Gail the
opportunity to complete my education
they declined politely so long as the
Cornell instead I it worked out all
right I'm happy to be here now four
counts but what I want to draw from in
particular was his 1961 book called who
governs and this is his attempt to take
a hard look is actually at the New Haven
government itself and say okay well we
know you have political actors you have
elected officials you have elites from
the town as well business interests but
how do all of these forces come together
does this resemble what a democracy
supposed to look like with majority rule
and participation and he's focusing on
to what extent did the mechanisms in
place formal and informal translate
power into decisions and what he found
was that no it didn't exactly look like
she drew it up in Athens but you had a
system that worked pretty well these
competing interests that would combine
coalition's they would compromise in the
margins and he looked at this pluralism
vision of pluralism and said you know
this works pretty well well I want to
take this question of who governs and
ask that of this field who governs
nuclear energy and I'm sure that the
morning is already touched on some of
the key issues that warrant governance
but the development focus on for safety
ensuring the public environment or not
harm from nuclear facilities waste
management the long-term care of
hazardous by-products proliferation
continue to spread of nuclear weapons
and economics both markets and
advancement technologies want to start
to think about
evidence in this context I immediately
began post World War two with the
founding of Atomic Energy Commission
this was the answer to who governed they
were given the monopoly control over all
nuclear materials and nuclear facilities
in the United States now in that moment
in time their focus was a military one
this is trying to build upon the
Manhattan Project and establish a
weapons program the civilian
applications got pushed to the side for
a bit but by about 1948 they turned
their focus more towards civilian uses
and they started to look at prototype
reactors and because they had this
ability to enrich uranium from the war
it there was a broad range of
technologies that were available to them
and they built basically one of
everything they could think of an Idaho
with at the side of what's now the Idaho
National Lab I think that process
culminated in my mind around 1953 when
the experimental breeder reactor EBR one
produced electricity on the grid from
one of these prototypes and I think
around that point the aec saw it was
time for a bit of a shift that need to
look more towards larger scale
demonstrations not of the five and ten
megawatt more of the 50 60 80 range this
has been a challenge though because for
all of their staffing up on an
increasing in size they weren't capable
of executing demonstrations at the scale
and this led to the realization that
they needed to have private partners as
well as part of this development program
the atomic energy act in 1954 made this
possible a lot for the private ownership
of nuclear facilities nuclear materials
and sure enough you had a series of cost
sharing demonstrations that followed in
the subsequent years pressurized water
reactors boiling water reactors sodium
heavy water high temperature gas
reactors I think I'm missing one or two
but this also in spawning these
technologies and doing so with private
interest as well it changed part of the
focus of what the aec now had to do it
also bore the responsibility now to
regulate the activities of others
just gave it a dual hat had is both
trying to promote the opportunities for
civil nuclear technology at the same
time ensure that they're done safely
responsibly I'll come back to this in a
moment they're on the same time they
were also beginning to take stock of the
challenges with waste management now
this was not yet from civilian cycle as
I said I was just not standing up in the
late 1950s but they had quite a bit of
well they made a bit of a mess during
the Manhattan Project and in 1957 they
turned the National Academy of Science
say okay what do we do with this and the
answer they came back with was deep
geologic disposal the AC went out to try
to begin that process find a site find
the right kind of geology and they
didn't do it very well the the site they
found was in Kansas it was a bit of a
failure that didn't didn't work it and
so one of the last things i mentioned to
was the notion of non-proliferation and
here i want to turn away from the aec
for a minute and turned back to dwight
eisenhower there's around the same time
that we were producing electricity in
Idaho he was doing front of United
Nations to give his famous atoms for
peace speech in here in this he laid out
the fearful atomic dilemma that there
was the promise of nuclear technology
that could address many of society's
great needs for abundant energy but at
the same time the development was rooted
in weapons production and the question
was how could you divorce these in his
language it was you know the to ensure
that the miraculous inventiveness of man
shall not be dedicated to his death but
consecrated to his life it's better than
I was saying it and this set out towards
creating an institution that could help
to arrange this this balance between
patrolling the weapons
technology while maintaining in
promoting the civilian technology this
manifested in 1968 in the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty which had a few
basic components one was that states
that did not have nuclear weapons would
refrain from acquiring them since that
did have them would commit towards the
eventual elimination and third all
nations would be entitled to access to
the beneficial uses of civilian nuclear
power but now if I take all these pieces
I've just thrown out there and asked how
they fit together I get kind of a bit of
a jumble because i had the aec at this
point and the early 1970s on 10 i was
born casey has this extensive weapons
program that their manager they're
beginning to address the waste problem
if not with great success they've
established a rapidly growing civilian
nuclear energy program at the same time
they're also tasked with maintaining the
safety of that program what the aec
provided during this time was a
persistent support for new technology
development there was this ongoing
expectation that nuclear technology and
nuclear research was going to be part of
the future and you could plan
accordingly but the the ability for one
entity to govern this was beginning to
fray and this is widely recognized and
we begin to see in the 1970s a
fracturing of this governance structure
where you'd have more actors more
institutions working in different forums
that would tackle different aspects of
these problems not one institution of
them seeing everything and what I begin
to think of this kind of complex notion
of different actors at different levels
interacting in different places I
reminded of you know I'm often hear the
phrase that oh well I'm sure there's
some German word for that it covers it I
don't speak German but i am at yale and
it turned out Robert Dahl had a penchant
for coining his own terminology as well
because when he was trying to clarify
and explicate some of these complex
systems of governing
he often needed to find words and
managing themselves if he picked one
along the way that was one of his
enduring contributions political science
called the polyarchy which something
that I won't claim to use it in exactly
the way he meant it but I'm going to
claim it for a little bit right now
anyway first convenience but the
polyarchy was about in his mind was the
realization that democracy couldn't be
implemented in its idealized form in a
modern system it was more complicated
from that Nepal erica was the messy way
in which he had institutions that still
enabled the participation of the broad
public and managed the competition in
which these things these questions were
evaluated and what I like about the
polyarchy is this notion that it's
multiple layers from different
directions because I think that's what
begins to convey the complication that
follows in the 1970s non to today and
how we think about the governance of
nuclear energy let me begin by
revisiting non-proliferation and one of
the first institutions that was added to
this poly argue in the immediate
aftermath of the Eisenhower atoms for
peace speech it was a call for an
establishment of the International
Atomic Energy Agency the auspices of the
UN the explicit point of the IAEA was
that proliferation was going to be a
multinational problem this was not a
question for one government to take on
but one that we all had to do together
when we look at things like even the you
know quite high profile or on
negotiations of recent weeks which my my
boss was really hadn't role in one of
the things that I don't think was a well
appreciated was it wasn't simply the
United States and Iran at the table it
actually included Russia China France
Great Britain Japan and the European
Union it's a multinational problem and
the institutions that have been built up
including things like the Nuclear
Suppliers group recognize the
multinational aspect of this and it's
not to say that the institutions that we
have are the ones that we need
persist with going forward though but
what's this I mean not that the IE needs
to go we can think more broadly about
how we approach non-proliferation and
before secretary Moniz was in
Switzerland or even a department energy
well well its recent apartment is use it
before too he was exploring this idea of
nuclear fuel leasing as a way to think
about adjusting non-proliferation and
here we have a different approach which
is to say if what I'm really worried
about the end of the day are these fuel
cycle technologies the same ones that
can be used to develop nuclear fuel for
reactor operation so ones can also be
applied for weapons production as well
into most conditions well if I have
states that have the full fuel cycle
there's an opportunity for them to
provide fuel to reactor states who don't
need to have the fuel fuel cycle you
just want the benefits of nuclear power
and take that fuel back and manage it as
part of our own spent fuel quantities in
the US we produce about 2,000 tons a
year and so is there an opportunity to
begin to explore these kinds of a grid
of arrangements to halt the spread of
enrichment and reprocessing not
necessarily by saying thou shalt not but
offering a better deal to those who
would be considering this of course
doing that would actually involve making
sure that we actually had a functioning
complete fuel cycle and no we haven't
quite gotten there yet I go back to the
notion of who governs this aspect well
when the aec went away and the
department energy stood up this is one
of the functions that went to the
Department of Energy this waste
management function and it was really
made more clear in 1982 when the nuclear
waste policy act said you know what the
department of energy will also be
responsible for the long-term management
disposal of civilian spent nuclear fuel
we enter into contracts we said you know
that this date 1990s and after we will
come and pick it up and we'll take care
of it the part of energy then one often
started to look at various sites to go
do this
1987 we were directed to say just focus
on the one in Nevada and I think it's
safe to say that we've learned since
that is the governance of nuclear waste
management isn't simply a question of
what choices the federal government is
going to make that we ran into a great
deal of opposition that perhaps started
small but it certainly got worse over
time and forced us to step back in
recent years and say wait a second this
approach that we've got isn't working we
need a better way and we turn to
secretary Chu turn to the blue goo
Commission for America's nuclear future
and ask them help us to think about a
more effective way to do this we're
fortunate enough to have one of the
members here at least one that I know of
and coming out of that the
administration put forward a strategy
for the management of use fuel and
high-level waste and the key themes
there that I keep focusing on or one's
all about governance it's establishing a
siding method that's built upon consent
of localities and states as well as the
existence of the government it's trying
to establish a new federal entity that
would be focused on this mission only
the realization being that if this
mission were having to compete against
other priorities in a budgetary context
with a diverse agency with many needs
you can lose focus and that focus was
something that was sorely needed and so
this governance has continued to evolve
from the aec doee to where we're trying
to go into the future and we're still
hopeful that we can begin that process
soon and forward to the opportunity to
put more dramatic from congressional
legislation in the future i also want to
shift gears now to the notion of the
governance of safety
the most clear example of this idea of
the evolution of governance from the aec
move forward was the establishment of
the Nuclear Regulatory Commission itself
the expectation that the realization
that you can't ask a regulatory agency
to also be responsible for promoting the
technology the same time those are
different imperatives and need to be
treated separately and this need for
independence that I think has been
proven to be very significant in the
subsequent years but the same time I
don't want to make it seem as though the
NRC once established was a finished
product in this time in recent years
we've been working through different
licensing approach for new reactors so
it's still the NRC still the
independence but trying to find
different mechanisms by which you can
accomplish the goals of ensuring safe up
or safe construction and operation
design of nuclear technologies it nor is
the governance itself limited to the US
government as well institutions such as
in po the institute for nuclear power
operators thank you i wanto the world
association nuclear operators have also
tried to focus on the industry best
practices in the dissemination of those
as well as part of this overall approach
to saying how do we as a nuclear
enterprise approach this question of
safety the turn now to some the economic
questions I think these have been close
to the bone for me and where I tend to
focus on these issues so when Robert
Dahl asked the question well who governs
the market his answer was the price
system which is fair enough point but
even that asked the question well how do
you govern the price system and
historically and even still but half the
country the answer was fairly
straightforward we had monopolies in the
form of utilities that were allowed to
operate as a natural monopoly with the
that they would be regulated by the
states to ensure that there would be a
reasonable rate of return for their
investment but nothing that would enable
users the rates in the customer and
that's still except in the case about
half the country right now to the at the
same time we've also seen a drive
towards a restructuring of many of these
markets that the problem with the
regulated model is that it has seen that
in many cases the incentives weren't
correctly aligned that you you could
provide in theory a lower-cost product
with better competition by enabling
wholesale power markets to be
established and that's been what we've
seen in the Northeast in the Midwest in
particular Texas with I think some
unexpected results of times for how the
nuclear power is with fitting within
that structure in these markets the way
they basically work is for all the load
that's being demand at any given point
in time the least cost plant is being
sent out first the one that meets the
last megawatt hour of generation to meet
that load that's the one that sets the
price and in many of these markets
that's been natural gas for many years
that's been that marginal price setter
and for much of the time these markets
were established which basically goes
back 15 years or so these aren't the
long-term 20 years 30 years gone cold
these have been long-term institutions
much of that time with natural gas
setting the price the wholesale power
prices were much higher than we've seen
recently and nuclear power plants did
very well in these environments sent in
general you could sell at six cents a
kilowatt hour and produce it to sentence
you did pretty well but in the in recent
years been new pressures that have
changed some of the economics of nuclear
first of all it's not really two cents
to produce any more it's more like four
and even there's a pretty broad range
around that depending on what size you
are a whole drawer and where you are but
also the power prices themselves have
come down quite a bit the natural gas
revolution has
affected the electricity prices as well
in this manner and we now see challenges
in places like it plants like Vermont
Yankee nearby kewanee in Wisconsin
operating plants that were running very
well that were forced to close because
they could not make a profit in this
these market conditions and this leaves
a bit of conundrum because when i think
about climate change and the role that
nuclear energy can play in addressing it
i see a need for a lot of nuclear
reactors I don't care which kind I just
need a lot of baseload non emitting
sources of electricity at the same time
I'm seeing perfectly good plants that
can't continue to operate in these
conditions and I think this becomes an
opportunity for policy now i put on my
economics hat for a moment and the
economist answer is a pretty simple one
you see oh you have an externality an
externality is easy to solve you tax it
right up to the point where you cover
all the costs from that externality that
would've being imposed okay that sounds
easy enough except that we're talking
about irreversible climate change how
much economic damage is caused by
academic by climate change that's a hard
problem and right here at Yale William
Nordhaus has done as much as anybody in
trying to understand that question and
be able to quantify how you might make
that attract to a problem but I have a
secondary problem which is that even
once i get to the optimal carbon tax I
don't really have a political system
that's inclined to impose it so instead
I tend to have a a price on carbon that
is marked at the one number i know can't
be right and that's zero
in light of this we've had this thought
of it as policymaking in purgatory that
I can see what the future needs to look
like yet the conditions i'm operating in
now don't leave me a path to get there i
think there's some cause for hope i
don't mean to sound dour I'm actually
fairly optimistic in the long term I
think the clean power plan that's being
proposed by the EPA and I think will be
discussed a bit more later is an
opportunity to at least create the
economic signal that says no this is
something that needs to be considered
that the greenhouse gas emissions are
important then we need to find a way to
factor that into private decision making
in public policy making but at the same
time there's another dimension as well
to the economics and in there a look at
the opportunities for technology
advancement and this is where my office
comes in along with industry National
Labs we look at is with the barriers to
entry for developing these technologies
what are the appropriate public roles to
ensure that the technologies for nuclear
can be available to the marketplace a
timely manner to meet these public
challenges in the Department of Energy
we focus on all manner of the nuclear
enterprise not exhaustive but light
water reactor sustainability R&D to
understand what the aging challenges are
with the current fleet what can be done
to assess the the conditions the
expectations for how they're going to
evolve and what that might mean for
providing technical basis to evaluate
license renewals beyond 60 years we
supported the development of the
advanced light water reactors the gen 3
plus systems the ap1000 spwr from GE
ones that tried to incorporate passive
safety and work through the licensing
process to make these commercially
available do cost sharing and like we
have a similar effort underway now
looking at
small modular reactors these are
technologies that have characteristics
with safety and economics that we think
can expand the range of how nuclear
energy can play with in this economic
landscape but the same time recognizing
there is a significant cost and time
barrier to reach in commercialization
it's on the order of 500 million dollars
that's a pretty large investment for
companies to try to take on to Murray to
marketplace that they will be making
such decade out we provide support to
help that process as well we also have
interest in understanding and pursuing
advanced reactor concepts as well these
come farther out in the timeline in our
expectation beyond 20 25 maybe even
later but in these technologies by
changing the coolants by changing
moderators but they open up the
possibility of having a broader range of
fuel cycles perhaps or a different set
of business characteristics and economic
features that enable nuclear to be
applicable in areas that it wasn't it's
not in the light water act technologies
we own the feels like a problem and that
means from our case it's ranges from
trying to establish things like interim
storage for nuclear fuel except that we
can the understand the transportation
the issues then the disposal of
longer-term as well but also the
exploration of advanced fuel cycles are
there better ways to do this or their
different fuels we can have the vote for
safety you for the long term waste
management and one of the things at a
point to as well along these lines is we
recognize that any work and nuclear is
difficult and expensive there's a lot
that goes with it you to be responsible
and that's not a quicker cheap operation
we've put a great deal of effort into
developing and then exploiting the
capabilities provided by
high-performance computing the
Department of Energy owns some of the
most powerful computers in the world we
can use this to simulate from the
atomistic scale to the long-term waste
management scales we can these systems
one of our recent efforts is to work
with industry and the National Labs to
create a virtual light water reactor
core that allows us to do investigations
and problems that were otherwise
unavailable to us to for sensing and
detecting as well and in the hope is to
be able to use these tools down the road
to design new systems and reduce the
number of demonstrations and tests
required but the same time expanding the
range of what's capable in these
technologies but with that being laid
out there I want to come back to my
initial question which is who governs
nuclear energy and as we've seen the
evolution of the nuclear enterprise
we've also seen a parallel evolution how
we approach governance and what I see is
an increasingly increasing focus on
specialization and parts of the problem
and a focus on safety or proliferation
or waste that you know these the
creation annotation of institutions and
forums that are tailored to more
narrowly define realms and what I take
from that as I look back at the purpose
of this conference and how nuclear and
climate change will fit together I come
to conclude that within the nuclear
enterprise nobody has the authority to
say I'm going to make the decision
that's going to make nuclear the
technology that's going to be a have a
significant influence
climate change we can work on parts of
the problem we can improve every aspect
of it and that will and self make it
easier but this question of who gets to
decide well it seems my perspective it's
broader than nuclear and it's more about
climate change that the the policy
issues that will enable nuclear to move
forward to create the market demand to
pull these technologies into the system
will be ones from a policy that says
we're going to address this challenge
seriously and that brings me back to
Robert Dahl because when I think about
how we seek to acquire a societal
consensus around climate change I think
back to some of the concepts that he
worked on as he looked at the questions
of pluralism and polyarchy it was as
part of a larger mission to understand
if and how democracy could function in a
modern complex society and his core view
was driven by this the belief that the
principle of majority rule and the
democratic ideals were the ones that
could create the most sound basis for
governance and provide the societal
consensus that we need to tackle these
kinds of issues underlying that vision
was also a conception of how political
power and influence to be used in
society he had a scale they used to
describe how to basically rank order the
various kinds of influence went exert at
the bottom was physical violence not too
far from that was coercion and threats
but the top of that scale was the notion
of rational persuasion that people can
have a dialogue to evaluate what the
core interests were for at members of
society and
use that as the mechanism to come to a
consensus around how we as a society
should move forward and that brings you
back to this conference and Yale but I
think this kind of a discussion seeks to
inform that notion of rational
persuasion that this is where we come to
grips with what the challenges are what
we can do and how we want to go about
achieving it with that I thank you for
letting part of this dialogue and if
there's I'm willing to take questions
for few minutes at this time thank you I
Elizabeth Peterson from dominion I was
wondering should a carbon dioxide
national ambient air quality standard
talking about policy sure let me let me
take it this way i'm not picky i will
take anything that provides the
incentive that says there are important
aspects to the system that aren't being
appreciated and so if it's an air
quality standard if it's a carbon tax if
its cap and trade if it's a clean power
plan I think all those point in the
correct direction and I think of many of
the the specifics of you know say carbon
tax versus cap-and-trade yeah there's
some academic the distinctions and I'm
happy to delve into them because of my
policy wonk mind and still want to go
there anyway when I step back the
important thing that I see is we need to
have that policy signal to say that to
create the economic incentives to value
the things that we know are valuable and
we don't do a very good job of that and
I think in some of these markets that
we've seen the challenge is now they're
grappling with this and over time
they've tried to evolve as well things
capacity markets ancillary services like
these are aspects that they realized
just pricing the energy wasn't doing a
good enough job of catching other things
because it turns out that though were
these markets are designed to price
electricity we're actually trying to buy
a system that produces the a literacy as
well and figuring out what the key
attributes of that system are I've been
an ongoing challenge and I think it's
one that everyone recognizes and think
they're working to address but I think
that's where I hope to see more progress
in the next few years you mentioned a
lot about the economic and technical
risks and government's role or policies
role and trying to help with that
something that you didn't really touch
on at least or I guess at the end you
did was more than non technical or
social risks around public acceptance of
nuclear and you talked about this idea
of rational persuasion I was just
wondering if you could speak a bit about
government's role in that in policies
around public acceptance of nuclear
technologies that's a really good
question and I guess the one thing that
that comes to mind immediately is I
don't know that you can have a policy to
induce public acceptance or if so I
don't know what that would look like I
think you can do is have policies that
address the concerns than the public and
this is where I think the independent
regulator is the first and foremost in
my mind that if I'm up here saying these
things are great my office is going to
build them for you must sure they look
like and oh yeah and they're safe that's
not the same thing as having someone
from the outside who said I'm an expert
I've looked at every aspect of this I
can think of that doesn't solve all
aspects of acceptance but one thing that
think that when i was looking at this
notion of governance we didn't do a very
good job of this and many dimensions and
they waste is a pretty good one that at
having the policy in place we assume
public acceptance would be expected to
fall in line
it didn't work that way and we're
learning that lesson again but I think
that you the core of your question is is
very much on point which is that the
technology economics the technical
characteristics of the system are one
part of it but this is all embedded in a
social system as well and I think
opportunities to understand how nuclear
fits within the social challenges being
faced in climate change as well is I
think one of the most significant
challenges of the day it was part of the
reasons I'm happy to be here and take
part in this one last question perhaps
or yes
thank you for the talk this is a really
basic question I'm wondering what are
your thoughts on the Germany's decision
to retreat from nuclear energy and the
implications of this their decision it
is going to trigger other countries to
retrieve from nuclear energy as well
that is a good question and even in the
bio I mentioned that one of my roles is
in the nuclear energy agency of the OECD
which includes Germany as well and my
first thought when I heard this was that
Germany is a wealthy country and they
have the opportunity to define the
system how they think they want to if
prices are going to bear I however I'm
Cree a concerned though that there the
vision to leave nuclear will continued
we'll end up resulting in more emissions
in the sense being that the challenge is
climate change then if you can conceive
a system that has all renewables and
somehow make that work I don't
understand how that would work in a
practical level but if you can do it and
you willing to make that investment I
can seems like a extra costs and to my
mind but I couldn't leave port path
forward my fear is that by falling such
as approach the neck the consequence is
going to be to retreat a bit on the
climate change questions I think that's
an unfortunate path for it that's what
happens as far as the notion of other
countries following I guess I haven't
seen that at the same time Germany was
making his decisions the UK has decided
to press forward with a significant
nuclear program that's its approach to
me climate change as well we've seen
neighboring countries in Europe also try
to move forward with nuclear Poland in
particular hungry as well so I don't see
that secondary effect but my my core
concern is this the idea that these
challenges need to be thought of within
the context of this broad challenges on
energy and climate and I'm afraid that
how that ends up in Germany won't be
where I would prefer it would have been
hi my name is EDD file uh we don't have
anyone speaking of from the EPA today I
was wondering if you'd be willing to
comment on the new proposed rule or the
rules that are supposed to be coming out
in June that tried to kind of segregate
the different fuel or energy cycles for
instance making nuclear and hydro own
account is like six percent and favoring
gas and not favoring coal is that really
an energy policy because it's trying to
fix which fuel type is being used but
not necessarily reducing the co2 at you
can give a quick answer because that's
part of the next panel as well my answer
will be quick because it's not a lot i
can say on that as part of the
Department of Energy we have standing as
part of the interagency process with the
rural development and since it's still
in draft it was not appropriate for me
to comment on it in its current state i
will say that i can talk about the
overall intent though and i think that
the using the authorities to try to
create the economic incentives for
valuing carbon even in an imperfect way
as an improvement over where we have now
we just did not do it at all but with
that i think next channel panel coming
i'll defer for our discussion to that
all right thanks very much thank you